all right miles are you ready to get
technical I mean I think we've been
pretty technical all night child's play
we all know that computer images are
made up of pixels or a 2d grid of color
information right yes yes everyone knows
yes come on yes stick with me on this
wander and I knew that well creating a
volume requires a third dimension and
these 3d pixels are called voxels
and while voxels can contain color
information they are also used to
contain all sorts of other information
that's incredibly valuable for
simulation when artists start designing
fluid elements such as water slime
clouds fire and smoke the voxels start
to add up as does the file size every
time we say voxels you take a drink
that's and that's kind of what we played
in rehearsal people really liked it was
a lot of fun for everybody the second
half is gonna go a lot quicker if we go
boxes so that's it voxels then I've said
it three times now so I'm changing
everyone the EMP sparse voxel format is
a data structure and system that stores
only the critical data while dumping all
the useless data creating a more
efficient file size to work with
developed while writing his thesis
Robert Brinson pioneered the concept of
sparse styled voxel data and their
application to visual effects modeling
and simulation it's become a standard
method for storage and it's something
that affects my life everyday
voxel in recognition of this the Academy
presents a technical achievement award
to Robert fritzen please come on up
so first let me thank the Academy this
is an amazing honor it's been 13 years
since I started doing that so that's a
lot of voxel drinking I need to thank my
wife she's been a tireless support
through half a hundred crazy ideas
including this one my life wouldn't work
without her so I love you and I really
need to mention my fellow entrepreneur
mentor dear friend Marcus Norton's damn
who really did the lion's share of the
work in taking this idea and many others
we had together and producing tools that
really changed how film gets made so
thank you Marcus